all right so the big game gave us a
brand new look at the upcoming Indiana
Jones 5 or Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny and throughout this video we're
going to be touching on the new
sequences that are shown here how it
might be tying into the rest of the film
some Easter eggs and why this honestly
is the best de-aging I've ever seen in a
movie there may be some mild spoilers as
we tie these new scenes into the plot
and characters we already know about but
grab your Fedora satchel and whip that
like And subscribe Button as it helps us
out but uh yeah yeah I'm I'm your host
Jared the Short Round of heavy spoilers
now let's get into the new indie 5
trailer
my memory is a little fuzzy
are you still a Nazi so this quick TV
spot surprisingly gives us a decent
amount of new footage and how some of
this is actually going to tie into the
supposed
synopsis that was released a handful of
months ago apparently taking place in
1969. nice this will see India and his
goddaughter Helena Shaw played by Phoebe
Waller Bridge getting into all sorts of
scrambles with ex-nazis who have been
hired by NASA during the Cold War to
beat the Soviets to space they have an
interest in the moon landing program
however are said to have ulterior
motives wishing and I quote to rectify
the world and make it a better place as
they see fit so don't be surprised if
director Mangold and Andy take this
thing to actual space yes we need to go
to space but this new spot seems to be
involving some time jumps which Mangold
did mention in an interview would kick
off the film stating I wanted the chance
to dive into this kind of full-on George
and Steven old picture and give the
audience an adrenaline blast and then we
fall out and you find yourself in 1969.
the audience doesn't experience the
change between the 40s and 60s as an
intellectual conceit but literally
experiences the buccaneering spirit of
those earlier days and then the
beginning of now the flashback opening
sequence in question here seems to be
the train sequence that starts
everything off with Andy and Toby Jones
character of Basil watching German
planes swarm the skies above them it
jumps back and forth here in this TV
spot but I solely want to focus on the
flashback footage first Indy seems to
have rescued his buddy basil as you can
see them casually walking to the Train
the train is sporting a Union Jack Flag
and some tanks and other military
equipment as cargo more than likely a
military transport this is soon taken
over though by the Germans specifically
mads Mickelson's Jurgen voller voeller
looks to need basil for something before
a de-aged Andy just sucks him in the
face now the D aging here looks
incredible even honestly even better
than the first trailer awesome I love it
but also explains why this movie's
budget is close to 295
million dollars this is 1969. that
amount of money doesn't even exist
moving on the meeting obviously goes
awry because of the punch and German
planes begin firing on the Train
Transport another shot of a de-aged Indy
hiding behind some of the trains cargo
we can see some lettering of err which
was actually a primary German
organization in charge of seizing and
destroying Jewish and other cultural
properties in occupied countries during
in World War II this is similar to the
book burning scene in the Last Crusade
so it looks like the Brits have kind of
reclaimed some of this cargo and
potentially the dial of Destiny is what
bowler is looking for on this train
again this sequence more than likely
opens the film in the 40s as we then
transport to 1969.
[Applause]
[Music]
eat face to face after a couple of
decades and even though voler is now
working for the good guys he still very
much is a Nazi working under guys his
character is Loosely based on Werner Von
Braun who was a big player in the US's
role in the Space Race having helped
develop the V2 rocket for the Germans he
was working for them in World War II but
then was recruited after that by the U.S
as an engineer to help with their space
Ventures so it seems that there's going
to be a lot of who's actually on whose
side throughout this movie Bowlers have
we met line seems to be in line with him
keeping a low profile on his earlier
days and start a new life but Indy
doesn't forget so easily and it looks
like Boyd Holbrook will be kind of
working with voler essentially his right
hand man and muscle throughout most of
the movie it is cool to see how these
two kind of similar meetings play out
while a younger Indie is just quick to
pop in this guy in the face this 60s
Indie is like Roger murta in the Lethal
Weapon series
[Music]
again the space race and the moon
landing of 1969 is going to play a large
role in this as we can see Andy being
chased by holbrook's character during
the Apollo 11 ticker tape parade in New
York this took place on August 13 1969
and was done so in celebration of the
moon landing we then get our first look
at John Rhys Davies returning as the
Beloved asala from Lost Ark and also the
Last Crusade hopefully there's a nice
kind of friendship scene between the two
and then a send-off as we then hear him
yell give him hell to Indy as he uh goes
off
the action kicks in as we see a desert
like Rickshaw Chase and Rickshaw isn't
the only Shaw as India is trying to
rescue Helena Shaw from the other
vehicles the reason the two have crossed
paths could potentially be because this
is salah's daughter and indy was asked
to help her get in or out of the
scrambles that we see here the trailer
ends with Indian Helena aboard what
looks to be a heinkel
he-111 German fighter plane punching out
a couple of Nazis as then they Skydive
out of the plane
hang up there also appears to be a more
modern for the time private jet tailing
the fighter plane and with Indy
questioning why Helena is there it could
be the other way around where Helena was
sent to save Indy using this private jet
and then the desert motorbike Rickshaw
Chase happens after this because the
island that they're falling on looks to
have kind of a small City on its land
mass the ending feels very Keanu Reeves
in Point Break and I'm really digging
what we've seen of Indy 5 so far with
Mangold mentioning the flashback
influences that he wanted to Showcase
combined with the One Last Time Vibe of
the 60s Indy I'm digging this of course
this is a quick teaser maybe we missed
something but I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Indy five is this shape
enough to feel like the original trilogy
and what about those de-aging effects
that stuff is scary real looking right
now and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition giving
away 3 copies of wakanda Forever on the
15th of February and all you got to do
to get a chance of winning this is like
this video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on Indy 5. we
picked the comments at random at the end
of every single month and the winners of
last month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other big game trailer breakdowns
either the flash or guardians 3. but
with that out of the way thank you for
your constant support I've been Jared
I'll see you in the next one take care
and peace